près de 3 km de sable fin la plage des
lasascan Terrass est connue pour être
l'une des plus belles plages urbaines en
Europe bonsoir et bienvenue dans zone
Europe sur Radio sensation et sur tv78
pour un numéro spécial réalisé à
l'palmas des grandes Canaria en Espagne
voici tout de suite le sommaire de cette
émission zone Europe sur sensation nous
parlerons du tourisme entre janvier et
août près de 9 millions d'étrangers sont
venus ici au canari une île de vacances
prisée surtout par les Anglais et les
Allemands ancien journaliste de radio
sensation et de tv78 niikola kirilovitz
est installé ici il est l'auteur du
livre pour une révolution durable se
réconcilier avec la nature et le vivant
plus de 100000 Français vivent en
Espagne comme W il a quitté l'Hexagone
pour s'installer sur l'île de Grande
Canaria et y ouvrir un bar nous
reviendrons ensemble sur son parcours et
puis à la fin de cette émission nous
vous ferons découvrir le Big Bang
vintage festival un événement qui fait
la part belle à la culture et au musique
des années 40 à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tourisme est un secteur vital pour
l'économie de lîle entre janvier et août
2023 les Canaris ont accueilli près de 9
millions de touristes si la plage et le
climat sont évid très attrant l'île de
Grande Canarie a d'autres atouts à
proposer pedroivedo ma adjoint de
l'aspalmas chargé du tourisme nous en
dit
[Musique]
plus Palmas des grandes Canar est un
phénomène singulier au milieu de
l'ensemble de l'offre touristique des
îles
Canaries notre offre qui attire plus de
2 millions de personnes par an
s'articule aussi bien autour du sole
la PAL de
canano Palm des grand Canar est un lieu
urbain différent c'est une destination
urbaine nous prétendons ajouter d'autres
caractéristiques que le soleil et la
mer de ce fait nous avons eu des
contacts récemment avec un public avec
qui nous avions peu de relation qui est
le public français précisément avec la
ville de La Rochelle où se tiennent
quelques régates des mini transates que
nous développons entre La Rochelle et
l'palmas
c'est pour dire que nous travaillons
avec d'autres schémas que le tourisme de
soleil et de
[Musique]
plage pas seulement un avantage ce qui
nous
intéresse pour faire la promotion le
tourisme de loisir est un tourisme qui
est utilisé dans beaucoup d'endroit où
il y a plus d'espace de soleil de plage
mais dans un lieu urbain comme ici
les événements culturels sont
déterminants une destination urbaine qui
n'a pas d'offre culturelle ne peut pas
être une destination urbaine puissante
un lieu urbain c'est la sécurité la
connectivité les services mais cela doit
être aussi pouvoir disposer d'espaces
pour la musique les activités
culturelles puissantes les activités
sportives puissantes tout cela nous
l'avons oui et ça nous va plutôt
bien
le tourisme est un phénomène énormément
révélateur pour les Canar tant pour son
activité économique que pour son
développement
social le tourisme représente ici 35 %
du PIB des îles Canaries et 40 % des
emplois une chose
énorme à Palmas c'est moins c'est moins
car dans un lieu urbain la dimension
touristique est plus contenue mais nous
calculons que si 12 à 14 millions de
personnes nous visitent chaque année le
tourisme peut avoir aussi des
répercussions brutales c'est donc
quelque chose qui nous satisfait et nous
préoccupe en même temps car cela n'est
pas bon de dépendre d'un seul secteur
alors nous travaillons au développement
d'activités alternatives et cetera et
cetera mais c'est vrai que le tourisme
est extrêmement révélateur et il est
pour
tout il voir qui nous sommes car le
touriste est intelligent et il ne
cherche pas seulement à manger à boire
et à profiter du soleil il veut voir
quelque chose d'intéressant il veut
apprendre et connaître de nouvelles
expériences sur ce terrain l'artisanat
et ici nous avons un artisanat puissant
de qualité existe c'est quelque chose
qui est
attrayant moi-même lorsque je voyage je
recherche quelque chose de différent
l'internationalisation des choses a fait
que nous trouvons les mêmes ch danses
par du monde mais ce que l'on veut
trouver c'est ce qui est différent c'est
ce que nous essayons de promouvoir
l'artisanat représente exactement
[Musique]
cel de la que me dijo que siempre para
siempre estaría para m de la que decía
que solo una noche y despuéso má la que
se fue con mis ganas de amar mis ganas
de vivir no la vuelto a
[Musique]
encontrarjerjereserjer
lors de son discours sur l'état de
l'Union européenne la présidente de la
commission Ursula van derleyen a défendu
son projet de pacte vert européen
l'environnement c'est une problématique
majeure aujourd'hui mais en fait-on
suffisamment j'ai rendez-vous avec
Nicolas kirilovitz auteur du livre pour
une révolution durable se réconcilié
avec la nature et le vivant aux éditions
libre et
solidaire zone Europe sur
sensation bonjour Nicolas kirilovitz
bonjour vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste sur les questions
européennes et environnemental et vous
avez publié ce livre donc pour une
révolution durable se réconcilier avec
la nature et le vivant un ouvrage qui
traite de la crise climatique et de
notre vision pour y faire face alors
avant de parler du du fond de de cet
ouvrage pourquoi d'abord avoir eu
l'envie le projet d'écrire ce ce livre
cet essai alors très très HN hnêtement
ça va pas être vendeur mais c'était
vraiment un cheminement personnel il y
avait pas initialement quand j'ai écrit
écrit ce cet ouvrage cet essai parce que
c'est un essai je l'ai pas écrit en me
disant voilà je vais écrire un essai sur
tel sujet parce que je suis x personne
et que moi je m'y connais bien là-dessus
et donc du coup j'ai quelque chose à
dire non c'était un moment dans ma vie
où j'ai quitté le boulot où j'étais euh
j'étais donc en face de de on va pas
dire de de de transformation mais bon
dans une phase un peu voilà de de calme
de transition exactement je pense par
que c'est le bon terme et euh et j'avais
pas mal d'idées à à exprimer sur sur ce
sujet dont vous venez très bien de
d'introduire les propos et donc je me
suis misise à écrire mais sans ambition
au début et donc je me suis misise à
écrire puis le temps passant je me suis
pris au jeu et puis voilà ma pensée s
ass c'est bien structuré en tout cas je
trouvais qu'elle se structurait plutôt
bien et et donc j'ai tout formalisé au
bout d'un certain temps ça m'a pris
quand même plusieurs mois et et je l'ai
proposé à des des maisons d'édition dans
un premier temps euh comme je n'y
connais sa rien j'ai proposé aux plus
grosses maisons d'édition évidemment
j'ai pas eu de retour ou que des retours
négatifs et puis ensuite j'ai
reformalisé ça dans un deuxième temps
j'ai restructuré un peu les choses et
j'ai visé cette fois-ci des maisons
d'édition qui étaient plus spécialisé
sur le sujet en question et peut-être
moins moins grosse donc il laisse la
chance au au aux auteurs qui débutent et
et donc libre et solidaire m'a m'a m'a
permis de d'être publié et de me lancer
dans cette aventure mais c'est une
nouvelle fois quand j'ai commencé à
écrire je me disais pas je veux être
publié je veux écrire un bouquin c'était
j'avais des idées exprimées je les mets
sur mon ord ateur et puis après ça s'est
formalisé les choses se sont un peu
emballé comme ça quoi mais sans sans
l'imaginer au début alors on va se
concentrer maintenant sur sur ces idées
que vous développez dans dans cet essai
donc pour se réconcilier avec la nature
et le vivant vous analysez d'abord un
modèle de vie qui aujourd'hui réglemente
nos vies c'est le modèle capitaliste
alors ce modèle selon vous a oublié
toute notion de naturel et et de vivant
nous a poussé en tout cas à oublier
toutes ces notions ouais alors après
c'est difficile moi je j'arrive pas à me
positionner sur déjà je pense pas qu'il
quelqu'un qui s'est dit un jour je sais
pas au 18e siècle ou au 17e tiens on va
créer un modèle le modèle capitaliste et
on on va se moquer du vivant et de la
nature et de et des écosystèmes parce
qu'en fait ça compte pas je pense pas
que les choses ont été faites comme ça
d'ailleurs c'est pas que je pense pas
c'est j'en suis sûr c'est que les choses
se développement se développant avec les
technologies et le monde qu'on connait
aujourd'hui voilà sont sont devenus
ainsi mais oui c'est ce que je pense
c'est qu'en tout cas aujourd'hui dans le
monde dans lequel on est au 21e siècle
euh il y a il y a du vivant on commence
à s'y intéresser
le vivant ça pour moi ça ça comprend
tout hein ça va du végétal à l'ours sur
sur la banquise au petit chat qui est là
à un microbe une bactérie tout ce que la
terre finalement a cré voilà exactement
je pense que c'est bien de voir les
choses comme ça et aujourd'hui bah dans
nos modes de vie notamment et
principalement occidentaux hein c'est en
Europe et aux États-Unis surtout que se
sont développés le modèle capitaliste
mais qui est en train de se développer
un peu aussi ailleurs sur les pays
émergents notamment ou oui parce que
tout je pense que tout le monde a envie
de bah tout le monde a envie d'avoir une
voiture moderne tout le monde envie
d'avoir le derni télphone les avantages
qu'il a procuré aussi ce ce modèle
vousfort de vie voilà tout le monde a
envie d'avoir le confort de vie ça se
comprend mais làdedans on oublie que
pour accéder à ce confort de vie c'estàd
que même pour construire une voiture et
ben il y a des éléments naturels et qu'
faut pas sacrifier pour juste profiter
de sa voiture parce que c'est une vision
finalement si on la juge comme ça c'est
égoïste parce que bah moi je profite de
ma voiture mais qui on on sait très bien
que demain on pourra pas tous avoir
autant de voitures et quand je dis
demain c'est peut-être pas à 10 ans mais
ça sera un demi-siècle ou un siècle plus
tard et c'est des visions et c'est c'est
difficile de se projeter mais on peut
pas oublier ce qui ce qui est en train
de de se passer et surtout de de se dire
voilà moi je profite peu importe quelles
sont les conséquences on verra plus tard
ce qu'il en adviendra non on c'est très
bien qu'il faut changer notre façon de
faire parce que parce que elle est pas
viable tout simplement sur les choses
sur lesquelles ce monde est possible
sont en train de de de disparaître et
les chiffres moi je suis pas moi je suis
pas scientifique je suis pas
climatologue ou quoi que ce soit mais
les chiffres on les connaît très bien il
suffit de s'informer un peu on voit les
chutes
biodiversité le nombre d'insectes qui
disparaît la pollution de l'air bref
tout tous ces toutes ces don qui disent
que si on continue comme ça ça va ça va
barder pour nous quoi alors pour faire
face à à cette urgence climatique il y a
plusieurs plusieurs échelles il y a des
fois on renvoie un peu la balle entre
bah c'est aux états de de faire plus
d'efforts ou c'est aux citoyens
individuels justement de faire aussi de
prendre sa part à l'effort vous selon
vous qui est le le plus efficace pour
lutter c'est à quel échelle finalement
c'est vrai que là aussi la réponse va
peut-être pas être en soit la plus ouais
la plus intéressante et la plus tranchée
mais je pense que c'est les deux euh
parce que même si on on peut estimer à
juste titre qu'il faut qu'un État prenne
des mesures
importantes voilà ou même un continent
l'Union européenne par exemple en tant
qu'entité prennent des décisions par
exemple des objectifs climatiques
réduction de 55 % des gaz à émission des
des émissions à effets de serre en 2030
par rapport à 1990 des de tels objectifs
ça c'est applicable et ça réussira que
si à un moment il y a aussi une prise de
conscience personnelle on peut pas juste
vivre dans la contrainte on peut pas
juste se dire ah bah oui parce qu'il y a
une loi parce que il y a un état qui
impose ça ou qui ne l'impose pas
d'ailleurs parce que souvent c'est aussi
ça qu'on reproche aux état de pas faire
assez ah
bah si on partage pas le point de vue si
soi-même on n pas aussi d'accord déjà
avec le constat alarmant qui concerne le
climat l'environnement la biodiversité
et et qu'on attend que seul les états
fassent parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui disent ça moi je pense que ça ne
marchera pas parce que ça sera vécu que
dans la contrainte alors que si les gens
sont déjà d'accord avec le le l'état du
des des lieux entre guillemets enfin je
sais pas si l'expression est bonne mais
l'état des lieux du monde dans lequel on
vit et bah s'il y a des mesures qui sont
portées qui sont intelligentes elles
seront déjà soutenues d'un point de vue
intellectuel par les gens elles seront
plus faciles à mettre en place si ell
seront pas juste ah on m'empêche de
rouler en voiture bon je vais prendre un
exemple très cliché mais on m'empêche de
rouler dans voiture avec mon 44 dans
Paris euh peut-être qu'on peut voir les
choses différemment et peut-être que les
États aussi seront moins on va dire
punitifs et beaucoup plus dans la
compréhension si les gens aussi
comprennent et mettent en place des
choses de leur côté et ça peut être des
choses tout à fait simples ça peut être
je pense on a tous on connaît tous ce
sujet là mais manger un peu moins de
viande un peu moins prendre l'avion ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas manger de
viande qu'il faut pas prendre l'avion
mais on peut très facilement réduire je
pense sans changer de mode de vie et et
en comprenant des des enjeux
contemporains et qui auront ces
applications là après mais tout tout ça
cette réduction justement engendre aussi
des des conséquences économiques au
niveau politique dans cet essai vous
défendez la vision euh d'une Europe
fédérale alors le projet européen euh
initial et selon vous trahi actuellement
par les decideurs par les politiques euh
aujourd'hui car les projets fédérateurs
sont délaissés au profit de de de
projets de satisfaction électoraliste
sur le coup euh pour pour être élu on on
on ne va pas aussi loin ou on joue sur
euh sur justement l'aspect national
justement euh que ce qui l'Europe a été
d'ailleurs construit contre les
nationalismes euh à la fin de la la
seconde guerre mondial selon vous
l'Europe serait un projet donc non
achevé à part sur le plan économique où
ça marche très bien et aujourd'hui
justement on en revient au au modèle
capitaliste où du coup bah ce modèle a
quand même apporté des des avantages à
l'Europe sur le sur la manière de vivre
sur le le confort mais aujourd'hui il
n'est plus adapté justement pour pour
cette cette Europe aujourd'hui n'est pas
adapté n'est pas prête pour répondre aux
enjeux climatiques c'est ce que vous
montrez un peu dans ouais c'est ce que
j'essaie de dire alors c'est vrai que
vous avez avais raison je pense que je
sais pas si les chiffres sont toujours
d'actualité mais je je crois toujours
que l'Union européenne donc les tous les
étatsmbles les 27 je crois qu'il forment
le la zone la plus riche du monde en
terme de PIB devant même les États-Unis
la Chine euh donc ça là-dessus on peut
dire que c'est une récite économique il
y a pas de il y a pas de problème euh
néanmoins je pense pas qu'à la base
quand on sortait de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale bon l'Europe était déjà une
idée plus vieille hein parceque je crois
même que Victor Hugo on parlait lui
lui-même d'un projet européen n'était
pas que de faire une entité économique
qui réussirait même si c'est nécessaire
parce que au bout d'un moment on peut
pas vivre sans les besoins satisfaire
ses besoins de nourriture de logement
donc il faut créer de la richesse pour
tout ça si c'est que basé là-dessus je
pense que c'est une trahison de des
promesses de départ qui était États-Unis
d'Europe et je crois que on a oublié un
peu les la situation dans laquelle on
était à la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale c'est c'est normal parce que
c'est maintenant loin mais on sortait
d'un tel chaos qu'on s'est dit au B
moment faut faut pas juste lier que les
enjeux économiques il faut lier aussi
nos destin et notre destin il est
aujourd'hui je suis désolé mais l'en jeu
numéro 1 il est environnemental et
climatique donc on peut pas rester que
sur un un enjeu économique qui certes
fonctionne très bien il y a rien à dire
je pense que on sait que l'Europe c'est
une machine économique qui fonctionne
avec ses défauts C qualité que moi je
peux pas juger parce que je suis pas
économiste mais dont on voit des des des
des enjeux dans dans les médias mais ça
suffit pas aujourd'hui parce que c'était
déjà pas la promesse de base et euh et
surtout que ça pas comme vous le disiez
aux enjeux dont on parle climatiqu ça
peut pas on peut pas juste vendre des
des des des avions de chasse ou faire
des plutôt des des avions commerciaux
type Airbus ou des projets de ce genrelà
et se dire bah c'est bon ça suffit au
gens non les gens aujourd'hui il faut
qu'ils s'allie entre eux et qu'on soit
français allemand polonais hongrois
slovaque italien bon bref qui qui peu
importe là où on vit on respire de l'air
on a les mêmes besoins la pollution nous
affecte de la même manière et donc on on
doit s'allier sur ces sujets-l et
d'ailleurs je parle d'Europe parce que
c'est le le projet continental le plus
avancé au monde mais il y a évidemment
que c'est même des des sujets qui sont
mondiaux et qui concernent toute
l'humanité je veux dire toute l'humanité
respire euh toute l'humanité a besoin de
d'accéder à des à des besoins naturels
élémentaires et donc c'est pas juste un
sujet européen mais vu que c'est celui
qui est le plus avancé et que celui qui
est le plus prometteur disons
dirons-nous c'est celui-ci sur lequel
j'avance et que je connais parce que je
suis français donc européen alors tout
même que l'Europe ne fait pas rien en
matière d'vnement il y a le pacte vert
aujourd'hui seul pourra rien faire c'est
ce que je veux dire aussi il y a
beaucoup d'ambition est-ce que cela vous
rend tout de même malgré tout tout ce
que vous nous avez dit est-ce que vous
êtes plutôt P pessimiste ou optimiste
pour pour l'avenir justement ouais
honnêtement je serais plutôt quand même
pessimiste même si même si je crois que
c'est pas un sujet de je je crois qu'il
faut faire le deuil en tout cas moi
c'est comme ça que je vois les choses
faut faire le deuil du monde dans lequel
on est et et qui va pas forcément aller
quand s'améliorer il va y avoir des
changements profonds à faire qui tout
façon si on les on les met pas en place
nous se mett trop en place pour nous je
sais pas ça peut être des coupures
d'électricité généralisé des coupures
des problèmes d'approvisionnement de de
carburant on l'a bien vu un conflit aux
portes de l'Europe avec entre l'Ukraine
et la Russie et à un moment on se
demandait si on allait avoir du du
chauffage pour ce pour sa énergétique et
excusez-moi c'est c'est très grave ce
qui se passe mais c'est l'armée russe
qui envahit une l'Ukraine c'est pas un
conflit alors on a on a évité peut-être
le conflit mondial mais c'est pas voilà
on est passé pas la première ou la
deuxième guerre mondiale imaginez demain
un conflit de ce type là arrive je veux
dire comment on fait comment ça com on
court dans les supermarchés un virus et
tout le monde s'inquiétait pour savoir
s'il va y avoir du du du papier toilette
je veux dire le monde dans lequel on vit
il va forcément pour des raisons
environnementales et climatiques euh
être modifié soit on prend les devant et
nous aussi on change on réduit nos nos
façons de vivre et on on les rapproche
un peu du d'un mode de vie plus naturel
ou soit on change pas ça s'imposera à
nous donc c'est pas pessimiste parce que
moi en soi j'estime que un mode de vie
plus naturel c'est pas quelque chose de
mauvais mais c'est vrai que si on parle
d'un point de vue tel que ma vie elle
est aujourd'hui oui je je suis
pessimiste merci beaucoup Nicolas kir
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle donc
que vous êtes l'auteur de cet essai pour
une révolution durable se réconcilier
avec la nature et le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vivant
buscasas canción la sensción sentir
[Musique]
con me dejaste deerer cuando menos lo
esperaba cuando má
teería se te fueron las
[Musique]
ganas
cette bâtiste a servi de logement à
Christophe Colomb lorsqu'il faisait
escale aux îles Canaris au début de ses
voyage vers l'Amérique la cassa des
colonnes la maison de colon est
aujourd'hui dédiée à l'histoire des
relations entre les canaris et
l'Amérique des expositions ils sont
régulièrement organisé comme celle de
betsab et Romero autour du Jour des
Morts tradition mexicaine un événement
dédié aux migrants décédé au cours de
l'année
dernière zone Europe sur sensation holà
bonjour betsab Romero bonjour merci
d'être avec nous dans dans en Europe
alors donc au en Europe nous nous avons
la tousin au Mexique vous avez el dia
deos muertos le jour des morts alors
nous en Europe on fait ça le le 1er
novembre vous cette tradiction 100 %
mexicaine qui s'est un petit peu
développé aussi au-delà en Amérique
latine elle commence quand est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en parler de quoi
s'agit-il bah ça c'est très important
espécialement maintenant de loin de
l'Amérique latine parce que en Espagne
bien sûr avec la conquête et il y a les
traditions qui se sont il y a une fusion
il y a une métissage et espécialement
pour C cette tradition qui sert et c'est
pas seulement fête c'est pas comme
halloween c'est halloween c'est c'est en
le CAD dans le cadre
deertos c'est une tradition vivante très
ludique très catartique parce que ça
sert à chaque famille qui a perdu
quelqu'un chaque année à l'année
qui qui est passé pour
faire un hôtelal deert espécial dédié à
la mémoire de la vie de cette personne
alors c'est dédié à la vie pas à la
morte de ces personnes alors c'est une
et activité qui commence dès qu'il est
passé il est mort et et de ce moment à
ce moment-là toute la famille s'est
réunie pour voir qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
mettre à l'hôtel de chaque maison alors
ils parlent de qu qu'est-ce qui était
important et au niveau de ses activités
de leur de son goût qu'est-ce quelle
boisson qu plat que tout pour décorer la
maison et pour invit aux autres le jour
le jour des morts à venir à partager
avec eux la cette
hommage célébration dédié à cette
personne alors c'est une façon d'
accompagner les deuil c'est une façon de
les vivre ensemble et ça pour moi c'est
quelque chose de
très ça ça aide parce que c'est sont des
moments difficiles et en il y a rien
pour partager ça tout est tout est
individuel et les gens ne ne ne ne
célèbrent pas la la vie de il se
rappelle de la mort et et ça sont des
jours j'ai vécu en France et et c'est
sont des jours tristes la T la tin c'est
triste et ici c'est c'est c'est c'est
finalement voir le positif oui bon c'est
c'est pas seulement voir le positif mais
avoir la permission de jouer à que ce un
jour de
les gens qui qui nous sont abandonnés
reviennent reviennent alors quand tu es
petit les les enfants apprennent de tout
ce qui tout ce que c'était la vie la
mémoire les goût l'amour pour la
grand-mère de du grand-père ou quoi la
personne qui qui est la la personne à
qui on dédi le l'hôtel et on on apprend
cette C mémoire familière à partir de C
cette célébration et je trouve que ça
c'est très intéressante et c'est ça qui
me fait l'idée de partager aux autres
pays et aux autres et cette possibilité
qui n'existe pas et vous partagez donc
cette tradition ici à la cassa des
colonnes à la maison de Colon avec cette
exposition qui s'appelle les escaliers
au ciel si je traduis bien en français
qu'est-ce que vous avez voulu faire d'un
point de vue artistique sachant que
cette exposition est unique elle est a
été pensé créer uniquement à partir de
ce lieu qui est la la cassa des colonnes
oui à partir de ce que j'ai appris quand
j'étais petite avec mes grande mère
c'était une comment dire avant d'aller à
l'école de Bard à Paris que j'étais à
l'école de bosard à Paris et savoir
qu'est-ce que c'est une intervention
éphémère une installation d'art éfémère
me faisait rappeler à ce qu'on faisait
ce qu'il fa elle faisait mais grandmère
finalement ce jourlà c'était la
générosité des pas seulement faire la
cuisine mais mais acheter les fleurs les
ingrédients tout ça parce que sont des
hôtels qui attaquent tous les sens non
alors pour moi et quand j'ai a tant
qu'artiste contemporaine d'abord je veux
aussi faire hommage à l'art populaire du
Mexique parce que je travaille avec
beaucoup des ateliers qui font les
fleurs à la main les fleurs faites à la
main et les avec la tuile que je fais
ces crins et tout tous les matériel
matériaux que vous voyez pour
l'intervention architectonique que j'ai
fait à la maison de Colon sont faites
par des atelier d'art populaire au
Mexique et c'est une des patrimoines
plus important du pays et ça aussi je
faire ve faire un hommage parce que ça
n'existe pas partout les pays ont perdu
cette tradition et du coup il y a
l'artisanat qui même s dit c ça c'est le
plus connu dans en Hollande c'est fait
en Chine non c'est fait pour le tourisme
et et ça au vraiment un un pas plus un
valeur traditionnelle et au Mexique ça
continue heureusement et c'est ça que je
j'apporte parce que je crois que il faut
préserver ces traditions de chaque
endroit et et parce que ces traditions
font l'union de la de la communauté soit
n'importe laquelle et je me rends compte
qu'à chaque fois que je fais le jour des
mort à n'importe quel pays ça ça éveille
une curiosité à cause du conceptte et
parce que aussi tout tout c iconographie
de la morte a permet la le design de la
mode du tatouage et du du design partout
alors c'est parce que il y a quelque
chose de de fort à tout ça et cette
exposition donc les escaliers au ciel
elle elle intervient aussi dans un
contexte particulier entre l'Europe et
l'Afrique on a vous le savez une crise
migratoire si je prends les les mois de
depuis janvier entre janvier et
septembre 2023 il y a eu 15000 migrants
qui ont atterri qui sont venus qui ont
débarqué sur les îles Canaris mais il y
en a aussi d'autres qui ont eu moins de
chance et qui ont ont trouvé la mort
vous souhaitez également leur rendre
hommage à travers cette exposition vous
quel point de vue avez-vous de d'une
mexicaine sur justement cette crise
migratoire que nous traversons en Europe
pour moi cette fois-ci c'est le plus
important c'est un hommage cette fois-ci
aux migrants de tout le monde qui on est
ont perdu la vie cette année parce que à
la place de que ce
problème devienne moins grave chaque
année je toujours c'est pire tu vois
c'est c'est comme si la politique
l'histoire
l'économie n' n'est pas à l'auteur de
l'importance de ce phénomène qui nous
qui qui nous dépasse qui c'est qui est
vraiment le plus important parce que à
la fin tout le monde on est migrant on
est forcé de venir à la vie à la fin on
est forcé de d'y aller à la morte on est
des migrants même de la vie à la morte
et et on peut pas dire je n'ai rien à
voir parce que aussi toutes les cultures
sont fusion des autres et espécialement
en étant mexicaine en Espagne à la Casa
des colones ça ça prend beaucoup de
signification que euh une culture qui
vient d'au-delà du du du de l'océan de
l'autre côté de l' européen et vient et
apporte la la couleur l'artisanat et le
et une autre façon de voir la vie et la
morte je crois que la culture à la fin
c'est la preuve de que les la fusion les
rencontres le dialogue entre cultures ça
enrichissit c'est pas quelque chose pour
avoir peur pour se pour pour refuser
alors je crois que la culture va en une
autre direction que la politique et que
l'économie et que si les gens qui aiment
bien l'art qui qui reconnaissent ce ce
que c'est la culture et vient
ici ça serait pour moi déjà quelque
chose si il pense euh à la migration
comme
e un phénomène qui apporte ai dialogue
et
nous beaucoup de façons merci beaucoup
mer à
[Musique]
vous
je vous propose à présent un voyage dans
le temps de vous immerger dans la
culture et la musique des années 40 à 70
à l'occasion de la 6e édition du Big
Bang vintage festival à Las Palmas
rencontre avec Francisco jaavier via
Gonzales le directeur du
festival zone
Europe
voilà merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
dans zone europeope vous êtes le
directeur du Big Bang vintage festival
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas ce
festival comment est-ce que vous le
présenteriez le Big Bang vintage
festival est un festival qui unit la
musique et la tendance de la culture du
rock and roll des années 40 aux années
60 le rock roll le swing la le punk
toutes ces musiques
sont le début de toute la musique que
nous connaissons maintenant qui trouve
leurs
[Musique]
origines pourquoi le festival s'est
concentré sur cette période du rock des
années 40 à
70 parce que c'est ce que j'aime le plus
comment vous l'exliquez
s'exlique je fais un festival qui me
plaît à moi d'abord et c'est nécessaire
que le public connaisse cette
époque je crois que le public doit
connaître la naissance du rock and roll
et le faire en plein milieu de la ville
de la Palmas des grandes canari en plein
cœur de la ville dans le parc
selmo permet que cet événement soit
familial et réunisse toute la famille
vous pvez ire une bière manger un
hamburger acheter dans un trck et voir
des concerts ou des DJ des groupes
nationaux canariens et internau band
naal CAN et
[Musique]
[Rires]
intern
des particularités ou là parce que nous
sommes sur une île c'est très difficile
d'être musicien sur les îles Canaries et
très difficile d'organiser un festival
sur les îles Canar car si tu fais un
festival très petit seulement les gens
de l'palm vont
venir si tu as un peu plus d'ambition
des gens des autres îles peuvent
venir ce que nous souhaiter at un public
de la péninsule et étranger
aussi être musicien dans les îles je le
suis aussi c'est très difficile car si
dans la péninsule ou en Europe il y a
beaucoup de concurrence avec des
milliers de groupes très bons mais sur
une île tu dois faire le double d'effort
pour te
promouvoir désormais nous avons plus
d'aide grâce au réseaux sociaux mais
cela reste toujours plus difficile
depuis une
île
[Musique]
à que par à quoi ressemble le public que
vous souhaitez attirer à travers ce
festival un public FID car plus petit au
plus grand le rock and roll et le
folklore de
touss personne qui n'aiment pas cette
musique même siim Leon ou l'électro le
rock rol la sol la musique disco et la
naissance de toutes ces
musiquesance je ne sais pas si vous le
savez aussi mais nous avons une tendance
des festivals qui s'engagent davantage
pour l'environnement pour être plus
durable aussi ici aussi on remarque
cela
si oui oui oui nous
aussici nous travaons en ce
sens nous ne sommes pas seulement un
festival de musique et
culture en plus aussi nous voulons en
étant en plein cœur de la ville protéger
les alentours avec des veres
réutilisables en faisant des actions
pour qu'il y ait plusieurs stands comme
la Fondation Foresta ou un marché de
recycl
il m en avant leet et apprennent au
grand public à prendre soin de la
planète je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur nous allons maintenant parler
de cette exposition qui est autour de
nous une exposition qui s'appelle rock
Etas on en parle tout de suite avec le
photographeav FIP
zone
Europe bon nous voyons donc derrière
votre exposition plusieurs photographies
de femmes qui jouent du rock and roll
comment avez-vous pensé à faire cette
exposition et quel
messageouztr
au cette exposition est un homage aux
femmes du rock
canarien du rock canarien est une scène
basique d'homme et cela est un petit
hommage que je souhaitais faire aux
femmes des 10 dernières
années il y a 64 photos et 63 femmes qui
jouent dans des groupes différents il y
a des chanteuses des guitaristes des
bassistes des musiques en tout genre
c'est une sorte d'hommage aux femmes
avec le processus d'autonomisation qui
se déroule au sein de la société en
général et de la musique en particulier
et dans le rock des î
Canaries
en este caso el rock hecho en Canarias
pues muchas graciascias
[Musique]
aerteando
tout quitter pour créer sa boîte à
l'étranger environ 150000 français
vivent en Espagne au Canaris on les
retrouve principalement dans les
secteurs du Commerce et du Tourisme
Wesley a 34 ans il y a 8 ans il a quitté
la France pour venir s'installer ici à
laspalmas il a monté son entreprise un
bar il va nous parler de son parcours de
son ration et de ses passions zone
Europe bonjour Wesley bonjour Corentin
merci d'être avec nous dans dans zone
Europe alors pourquoi avoir décidé de
quitter la France en en 2015 et de venir
s'installer ici à Las Palmas euh écoute
moi je voulais partir à
l'étranger à la fin de mes études et
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait en fait je
suis parti en Australie 1 an en Working
Holiday Visa et euh je voulais découvrir
un petit peu d'autres
horizons et et en fait ça m'a permis de
de rencontrer des gens de vivre des
aventures
euh assez excitantes et
euh quand je suis enfin en Australie
j'ai rencontré mon ex une italienne et
avec elle on est tombé amoureux et en
fait on a décidé de de d'aller
s'installer au Canaris par que c'était
proche
de autant de l'Italie que de la France
et donc voilà donc c'était ça c'est fait
un peu comme ça à la base et on je me
suis retrouvé ici en 2015 et ici du coup
depuis comment s'est passé ton
intégration ton adaptation à à cette
culture espagnole canarienne même bah
très bien très très bien rien à dire
plutôt bien tu es toujours par reparti
ouais ouais bien sûr disons que avec le
travail ça permet de de déjà d'avoir un
un rythme de bien s'intégrer
euh mais après les gens ici sont très
sympas euh la vie est est chill cool euh
puis c'est la une vie de un rythme d'il
quoi donc donc c'est très tranquille et
et à va dire on s'adapte très facilement
quoi tu as été influencé par la culture
espagnole depuis que tu es tu es ici tu
as pris quelques habitudes de nouveaux
sports de nouvelles activités de nouveau
ououis bien sûr bah déjà j'ai une copine
espagnole maintenant de Madrid donc je
mange beaucoup plus espagnol qu'avant et
puis euh et après par exemple c'est pas
tant l'Espagne mais bon en tout cas pour
l'Î le côté île je me suis mis au surf
par exemple et donc c'est on va dire que
c'est quelque chose que j'ai
appris un des un des
points un des bons côtés de Lille quoi
et puis euh quoi d'autre je sais pas euh
non la
nourriture le sport le paddle aussi
c'est très développé en Espagne c'est
vrai que c'est très très commun ici euh
les G c'est ici que tu l'as découvert où
tu en faisais déjà je non je connaissais
mais j'avais jamais j'avais jamais
essayé et ici on a on s'y a mis avec des
amis français et euh et voilà depuis
c'est une addiction quoi et donc on va
parler de ce bar maintenant alors avant
tu avais déjà un autre bar celui-là il a
été créé depuis quelques mois il
s'appelle bistro lumière est-ce que
c'est un peu un petit bout de France ici
à à laspalmas comment tu le vois ton ce
ce bar ououais donc comme je
t'expliquais avant en fait j'ai le quand
je suis arrivé sur l'île avec mon ex euh
on a ouvert un premier bar qui était un
bar plutôt on va
dire international enfin il y avait
beaucoup de choses il y avait beaucoup
de de choses italiennes à la fois comme
quelques petites choses françaises il y
avà on avait déjà des crêpes par exemple
mais des crêpes très basiques et euh et
bref on a j'été avec le bar pendant 6
ans et quand j'ai ouvert ce bar j'ai
voulu m'orienter plus sur un un truc un
petit peu français faire un petit point
de rencontre pour les les Français qui
sont ici par exemple et surtout apporter
un petit peu cette cette
culture notamment les les galettes les
galettes bretonne moi je suis pas breton
mais mais j'adore ça donc est-ce que les
crêes Françis ont du succès ici au au
can elles ont un certain succès quand
les gens goûtent ils aiment beaucoup
après comme ils connaissent pas trop il
faut leur peur encore de ouais il ils
sont pas trop habituéss sont pas trop
habitués ils aiment bien aussi le leur
propre sont habitués à leur petits plat
et donc c'est un peu sortir on dire
merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé ton
expérience avec nous dans Z
EUR zone Europe sur sensation zone
Europe c'est terminé vous pouvez
retrouver C émission replay sur notre
site Internet et sur notre application
radio sensation très bonne soirée à tous
zone Europe sur
sensation